welcome to this video coverage of round
nine of the candidates tournament in
cantonment disc this video is about the
game under Reagan with white playing
Peter Svidler as black yeah both players
before this round our own minus one
doesn't sound too thrilling and it
actually really isn't for both players
um and Reagan was on mine it's two-way
even in the stone but score the window
with the pile of to make it a little bit
better looking what's villa had an
up-and-down tournament he was on plan a
plus score almost winning against crumb
Nick flows two plus two then back young
and he lost them quite disappointing me
yesterday against kayaking so is now on
minus one and also just like I'd raking
basically out of it very difficult to
imagine those two players like winning
four in a row and contest um first place
still let's see what happened in this
game nevertheless it is an open Sicilian
so swidler gets to play the night off
his one of his main openings against
1.e4 he's also playing classical ee five
double king porn but his main opening
really has the night off and under
aching place age three this funny Lomu
from sets to become the main line of the
night off yeah probably am if you would
tell this the later inventor of this
opening done me when I'd off you would
probably have a good love edit that age
three shot in danger is opening yeah I'm
just joking a BTM um it's in fact quite
an interesting move to play but it also
shows in a way that yeah lots of the
main options over the years like Bishop
to e3 and Bishop c4 Bishop g5 all those
shark moves they really have been played
so much that people long for a new ID
inside lines at atria saw one of those
lines that have been neglected and it is
interesting g4s the IDM of course and it
sometimes prepares Bishop e3 just in
another way compared to f3 yeah Sudha is
playing in five the most night off like
move actually and if you would ask me
what what should I play against a tree I
would also recommend to go 5 um if you
play if I've against we should be two
and Bishop b3 for instance then there's
no big reason not to play it here um
there is just one point that black needs
to be aware night be three years under
against move here there is also 90 d to
e 2 which is arguably even the more
popular moves and the idea is to go G
493 and possibly g5f for later and here
I actually like the idea to play age 52
simply prevent this G form and this
leads to an interesting complex position
that has been debated on top level
recently but on Drake and Platon on I to
be three this will allow Bishop b6 you
have the typical square for this Bishop
and it also might prepare the move d 65
yeah in this position now and raking
plate g-form um it turns out i had to
look at the games that have been played
before um it turns out that this is
actually not a very popular option here
G for our more popular our Bishop e3 and
also a form there should be three for
example has some one point it makes the
65 relatively unattractive this kind of
position
it's quite quite good for white with
long castles is very nicely developed
and black hair spender lots of time now
a black black of course does no need to
play d5 you can play other moves to stir
there should be seven and and castles
for instance and then it's just an
interesting fight as usual in the night
off there is also the most F form that
has been played for example by bikes on
degree shock only last year against one
of anons seconds another Slav write a
check top polish player f4 be 5 f-5
bishop c8 was the funny the funny moves
that was played in Grisha quite a shag
and pre-show get an interesting position
yeah why is a g4 not so popular well we
actually get to see it in the game as
video just placed d5 and here it's an
entirely different story compared to
Bishop b3 because g4s is just a move
that does not fit too well and in this
position if you look at ed 5 which is
normal looking something like that
that's already a bit strange so you
shouldn't take on d5 yeah but what
should why do yeah well should be too
probably but after a simple move like
just 96 for instance isn't like just
better here yeah in fact I do believe
that like already has a very comfortable
position what exactly is G for doing
here besides weakening f4 black has an
easy development it can put out this
Bishop maybe queen here castles and put
rooks on CNT file it's very simple plane
and why it is also clear what white is
doing really like also has this extra
pawn in the center yeah this is not
really great and probably wipe and
raking in this position played the move
g5 after some thought yeah well sweden
take what else is down takes only for
guide we get to this position where
white has sacrificed a pawn for the
moment but well you can check that a
forum is simply lost black needs to
return the porn so we get to to this
position very very logically and yeah
well how to assess that um get the only
question here in my mind is that sorry
if is this this is just equal or it's
like playing for something here he
simply has to somewhat neat a pawn
structure as this g5 and h3 moves are
more weakening than space gaining this
is a key point if why should take there
is g6 very typical move and only then
the recapture with black having a very
nice pawn structure so why does of
course not not taking me th played age
for to check now we had this looks
traded yeah it seems that the only
question is is this so vulnerable that
black can actually play a for advantage
or is this just equal yeah and Rickon
played it precisely I believe we should
be seven castles long and now be should
be three this Bishop is just covering
those two pawns and also ready to
possibly prepare night jump to c5 yeah
this whole opening result is some not
very convincing for white and a draicon
has played some some really um yeah I
don't know how to call it um yeah yeah
he has made some opening decisions that
are really surprising like young when he
yesterday got the basic position
position of the chair and ankles laughs
chronic plate his normal line and then
he took 20 minutes to to answer that and
he played the line that pretty easily
like here leads to an equal position I
mean maybe he wasn't so ambitious
this game um you never know but still it
feels like like it's just completely
fine in this type of structure yeah well
yeah but should be 3s will replace rook
age for activating the rook the
pointless oops now not not like that
these two squares especially c5 can be
crucial with them a night possibly
dropping them we can check em all so
here what would have happened if white
plays Knight c5 p.m. like actually as a
strong move shop g4 and this is attacked
and needs to go to ask where you don't
really want to go like here no black and
just a drop back this night is not doing
so much here yeah Bishop g2 as mentioned
be six and A five black is controlling
those important squares and it's just
generally being solid yeah um there is
really not much of an idea for whitey
and to be honest he can and he does and
the game improved to be three night it's
now a really stupid looking piece I will
be covering squares that the opponent
controlled so he brought this over here
yeah well black also could have taken
which it's also very much equal played
rook g4 now women gallery see a position
where ET five hangs and we have a sort
of a repetition which came on here and
rake it actually play droop she wanted
after neck the capture they agreed to a
draw yeah them in this tournament a
stool that you need to play 30 moves
before you can agree to a draw and
exactly that we have here yeah there is
simply not much not much happening at
this
if if anybody then maybe maybe on black
to try but it's a very very equal
position I mean the idea that I had as
for black would be nice to e6 there
should be seven and try to grab the pawn
but this is far from being forced of
course White has many opportunities and
put a bishop p.m. a knight to f3
activate it is after all relatively dry
and yeah not very exciting this game
admittedly but we have played a number
of rounds already enter it's simply the
case that only first place calcium and
this is maybe a slight a slight problem
with this format if you have games that
feature two players from the bottom of
the table of course um it's it's it's
also sometimes um yeah I matter of
concrete preparation I am Not sure that
I draken really willingly thought okay
let's just draw the game and get it over
with it's may be the case that he had
thought of g4 earlier and had
underestimated or missa missa or just
wrongly remembered about d5 and
relatively quickly if you look at it you
see that it's not really a leading to
much but do you see that this dissipate
quickly maybe he had confuse them move
order or something and then we simply
have this not too exciting game alright
i hope you still enjoyed some
information about to the opening the
middle ganesan was pretty much very
straightforward and not much to to ya to
explain about alright thanks for
watching